for example i've been
recently reading mineconf
you know what that's the thing even
there's something
in there's probably things in mineconf
that are
not the surface level read if you get
all hung up on
on all probably all his crap about uh
you know his anger anger at jews and
this and that all this crap
it's like okay yeah that that's right on
the surface
try to get below that try to see you
know how is he
how is he creating the jews as a cope
somehow like how is he using why
why are they his his scapegoat and i
mean scapegoat in the
so randy gerard's uh concept of the
scapegoat i mean
in that sense whereas uh you know hitler
uses
it wants to make the the jews uh the
scapegoat
for world war one yeah i mean for me the
starting point
similar with ann rand is uh like
mineconf is not
a good place to search not just because
hitler is evil
but it's just not full of ideas no it is
not
it has its significance due to a lot of
historically speaking but
the starting point for me with hitler is
like to acknowledge that he's human
and to at least consider the possibility
that any one of us could have been
hitler
so like that not that peterson kind of
concept
also um jonathan height has a thing
about uh
the difference between hate and disgust
mechanisms and things like that and so
he used he
goes into the looking at uh hitler and
his
through his his diary entries and
journals and stuff like that to look
uh and see it more as the the discuss
mechanism then also try and see like if
there's any
evolutionary biological uh attachment to
this
whatever i mean you're right he is a
human being
any of us are we're all human beings
it's not
that it's probably jarring for people to
think but
we're we're all i guess supposed
potentially capable of just being in and
all these evil people in the world
think they're doing it for the sake of
good yeah
which makes them the most dangerous and
there's some there's differences in
levels of insane
i think hitler was way more insane than
stalin i think stalin legitimately
thought he was
being doing good i would say that's
probably true stalin it was
just outright brutal yeah he had he had
his five-year plan he had all those
other things uh
he just had a much lower value for human
life yes
and so he was willing to take make
decisions about what he actually
as a as a good executive
which he was of managing different uh
bureaucracies and so on
he was willing to make decisions that
resulted in mass
human suffering where hitler was
it seems like to me what much moodier so
allowed emotions and moves to make
decisions we also have to consider
um the different trajectories and how
where and when they were making their
decisions and i mean not by
time specifically but you know hitler
engaged into this this conflict
across multiple continents and then
that everything that comes with
basically
fighting the whole world stalin
had his conflict and then he really
mostly compartmentalized the rest of it
so he was dealing with his own
internal instead of dealing with the
internal and the external
so if stalin was put under a world war
scenario i don't know maybe he would
have eventually lost his marbles too
yeah i'm not sure that you that's you're
right the hunger for power
was more internalized for stalin he
wanted to control the land that already
existed as opposed to wanting to
colonize other lands he was
as nationalistic as hitler but uh
and was as capable and willing for
uh violent conflict as hitler for than
the aims of
the state yeah but he
he he centered and internalized
prior to then externalizing and moving
outwards
whereas even maybe prior to him there
was an interest to
continually push communism in an
aggressive sense following on the
momentum from the
the what 1918 revolution and
that the halting of that uh
through various aspects i guess in
germany part of that was
the the national socialist like they
they came up and then they were the
other ones to fight the communists and
so you had the two totalitarians going
after it
um but then in the rest of the world
that was not dealing with
um totalitarian aspects
it was just it wasn't gonna stick
especially in the west and other places
but
stalin seen just you know casually
thinking
like stalin decided to go all right well
we're not going to go just start
launching right into
more conflicts here we're going to these
dudes are going down so that's cool for
us
because they hate us and we hate them um
but now we're gonna we're gonna focus
internally and then we're gonna work
on growing at a slower rate and picking
our battles a bit more specifically and
of course there's you know you can get
to the
even this is after stalin but yeah you
got the besmanov type stuff talking
about subversion
in in cultural aspects
you